let's get it going and first up we have
is Shen Chan kena's levels berry out
taking his strut upstage
oh here we go taking his walk down
strutting his stuff with those beautiful
colors on that JEP look at this man
where's his coat he's favoring the comb
for windy up ahead
the pilot didn't tell me he might not
wear the headphone so it doesn't mess up
his hair at all and I know he can hear
me too I know I'm gonna be screaming as
well quotes at you just because you
won't put the headphones on buddy
but yeah up his opponent one of the most
decorated players in America gonna be
link or link boys taking quite a few
wins actually had his own hat trickery
won three majors in a road this past
year incredible performance time and
time again good to see him gonna get up
against Singapore first well you know
sometimes versus link or is in fact this
was actually supposed to be the first
match at another event another
invitational that ended up getting off
stream but we're going to have the
pleasure of seeing it
why on three nothing's gonna be missed
I promise so yeah first we're gonna
we're gonna show some kind words here
from Shanshan I didn't really have any
problems with any mad chops upset for
one wish I think the wrath of the six no
and that's as well so I put in extra
work to us this matchup I asked you know
in my country there's no as well players
so I actually ask for help from overseas
Japan in particular to her play against
me a lot so I hope that this actually
helps when the boy very thing
[Music]
Wow such an incredible player and also
talented with words this English is
insane it's so good
Wow but you know what like looking at
him time and time again
Shan Shan has been the second place King
for so long if he comes out on top today
for 12 years this will be this will be
his moment I I think that everyone had
like every person has their day where
it's like you know what I've been second
place for too long this is where the
shift happens and at world's first sure
Oh was he trying to show the camera
what was that clearly clearly his claim
to fame but you know I I do want to see
you Oh candies oh okay then he's like
I've got the sugar rush real quick okay
yeah it's it's it's been years and years
years sunshine and he's going up against
Link force here still has not gotten
those glasses fixed and you know I guess
if you don't win a damn choice okay look
at these frames if you was a medic if he
was able to win this I hope he uses it
solely to fix this glass like like
that's it he doesn't spend it on
anything else just just glass do you
know what they look fabulous the way
they are come on come on jet I feel
beautiful that is you get to see the
whole eyebrow movement now it's
optimized it's optimized as long as long
as it's a ruinous play right there's no
way actually it gives the frame
advantage get it depends how many stacks
of his hand are we going in No
all right so here we are actually gonna
be getting him get on the girl to pick
who's talking about through this to me
earlier today just like hey you know
what Alicia you know we talked about
Siegfried earlier but I'm really feeling
garrulous you know like people haven't
seen me do this matchup in quite a while
and I have a lot of confidence in it do
you know what I have a lot of confidence
in him so let's see what happens in Game
one here at the world Invitational for
Soulcalibur let's get it yeah I
definitely have a lot of faith in the
Carroll because you know his rule means
both secretin girls he feels that they
are both one
same enough lies oh yeah here we go good
damaging already oh my God look throat
let's go for his okey option though
decisive show on it get a little bit
space and going up respect one another
being right next to the short wall he
was not trying to do the one thing that
would make him use there's the GI gonna
get the lethal hit for free IDG are
maybe wanted to get that ring out but
just a bit far away you know
yo not taking the throw here we go
laughing have damaged the scrim hello
and he jumps over the law with the night
be recognizing that it was coming up
secondary he into middle school you
don't even know gym class look good we
go good pressure lock is facing yo [ __ ]
make a wait time and time again getting
a passive lately right now bite yeah so
one of the things that we cores actually
personally feels as his best Franks is
the fact that he can catch the
opponent's rhythm and a counter hit them
as they're deciding to press a button
because he understands when they would
do so he's doing exactly that that's how
he what are you showing so far oh he's
looking for a regio because the other
you're already showed the lethal in it
last time but link horns didn't buy it
got the hit right there it's gonna take
second round and he's on the point first
bars for Chen chant coming in though
he's trying to be a bit more aggressive
that's for sure they're both excellent
570 of the full damage I GDR in there to
entertain me just like that Cervantes
here we go the wall rising be be good
damage up in sole charge that is your up
to get away from me here we go okay
steps uh sure that's gonna do it yeah
thanks the sole charge you gets a lot
more damage out of that you know I mean
everybody gets a lot more damage on the
sole charge follow-up but still when it
takes around takes around
hey great shot my stretch I'm being very
defensive early on this time I'm not
taking as much of that and then neutral
game we played listen to the girls I
think you sprout get the lethal hit to
get off the GI
igt yard bang just like that rocket up
someday the damage for days
don't forget though they both have a
leader to work with who will stop at
first the GI against Isis showing cotton
three five seven right there with the
low and even caught him using either out
of the meter burn possibly was trying to
use a yard music yeah one of the things
you might be noticing oh you know uh
sure okay he's at the small wall it's
done and that's a full combo that's
gonna do it first came to link ores and
he's looking you know it's a half frame
tech printer calling it now half prays
to God like one gram no one frame less
of input lag thanks to the fact that
there's no actual thing on his glasses
yeah would you know what really
convincing matched for late gourds
there's panic levels very own Chad Chad
putting in that work getting a lot of
those leaflets getting really optimized
damage there as well but do you know
what it's that it's a working away at
him there's really been eating up these
rounds so let's see what happens coming
into this weather
yeah one of those things that was
helping him out in the law the next
round right was recognizing that the
blinkers was recognizing a rhythm of his
and he was kind of hitting him out at
every turn right and see you saw a lot
less Conor hips from link or is getting
not connecting so he was who's being
more patient with his play yeah walking
up guarding
just waiting it up right and look at
look at what it's doing now he started
to identify link Orton's rhythm and you
know
annotation annotation exactly trying to
turn the tides here the lake boys is
fighting back he goes how dare you try
to get a leg sweet on me not today
hey yeah it's negative what you tried to
go for a grab after that but he gets the
Oscar oh hi there okay little bit - a
actually day just like that link
risk-taking around back you know
initially massage tension with the
lately but no link where's the scrappy
he's great and make that come back no
matter what doesn't matter by an inch or
by a mile
he's gonna get this who the teleporter
look like Greg it's the - okay yeah here
it is these are the counter hits moments
let me be so strong at her when you're
right he's going to react l'm eight
until what John Tran wants to do
ken-chan however trying to change things
up okay coming in with the poke damage
you're not gonna see a ton of damage oh
here you get the leap oh let's go cut
the grab on the stuff IBG are finish it
off on the round yeah I was gonna say
they're both trying to play it neutral
in such a way that they wouldn't get any
short if like clean hit like that to get
a bunch of damage done to them but you
know sometimes it happens sometimes we
make one mistake to launch all right
great pressure out shin-chan still
without meters our youth here we saw how
much damage this did last time in the
set up a fight his way back he doesn't
have a bar like Shanshan has finally got
it gotta let it burn oh there we go
interrupts get away from me okay really
important I mean link or disease is not
exactly going to burn like super super
often but chenchen definitely figure it
out when he wanted to go for at that
moment
gonna try for over the girl for the
front of kid i dt r gets hit out and
he's gonna get full damage off back
all right here we go link or a lot of
his low damage to make sure he pokes
them down even further
okay but no further solving he talks it
at all Mike nor at this link with the
twig duck able to get under it now close
it out so he has two metres to work with
there is the possibility here we go he's
gonna bring the salt I just like
chilling it nobody still hold it on to
it yeah you got the ASIC right there is
done but you know when course besides oh
no he's gonna try and put us right back
with his own C and no thoughts as well a
fix
Oh didn't did not work there is no uring
here we are no longer in New York the
last call I mean it felt a little bit
like New York when he dumped him I won't
lie to you oh well then she could do the
streets real quick man I don't know
shin-chan right there shun-chan he was
able to get past the ER t just by
remaining nice and patient right and
then he gets the throw that was just
gonna get him over the small wall it's
one to one right now Jen channeling
course and at this point to be saw
adaptation have an adaptation but you
know what really makes a big difference
here as the position advantage of the
church is babe listen if you're keeping
linear with a lot of he's block him up
with a lot of AIDS for sure blue course
is doing a great job at that at the
moment there's going to engage on each
other that's when Shanshan was like okay
I'm gonna wait till you overextend and
that's my sidewalk my sidewalk over and
over again
reutilizing that and getting the
positioning advantage getting ring outs
can't get to that massive damage of the
wall yeah just just like you're saying
you know one of the examples was the
fact that he was able to sidestep
several different burns from Oh
here we yeah home turf go for garel all
right let's see what happens the stage
can get a little wonky sometimes so no
small walls had to do we all have to
throw get the launcher i TV aren't he's
also stocking up the boat that's right
oh man we're possible mix-up right here
for the round and there it is [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm so convincingly yeah he was
definitely just on there's an ass he
never let off why you breathin brother
no not today
GI bang gets a lethal hit again pick up
a backup take those shot baby freedom up
just like that trying to get as many
towards that we flew it across we can go
going right there he backs off he's like
you know the one thing I could do to
lose here is be next to the left so I'm
just gonna back off and I'll let you
hang yourself exactly especially lately
by Riskin there we go Oh er and train me
oh he was standing right there and I
didn't see a counter hit so I wonder how
he got hit on that one I'm not entirely
sure but let's see what happens next
both them do have meter to work with
Google pop it first okay big ol with
birds to get that extra damage out yeah
that's the thing is like liqueurs Carter
has no
she's gonna be using his meter for a lot
of other things and you may not see the
full charge of the Caesars that's
quickly all right where's like chef
change good spacing little defense oh
that's a big we're never going mad
damage out what's important is to set up
right here to a and then wall rising be
nice right there from link ec showing
sun's light she's not giving up just yet
shun-chan may be on set point but hey
I'm still in that I was trying to catch
the whip punished right there on it Oh
respect for each other you're not
willing to go in on each other so much
scared of initiation Oh the clash on
yeah unfortunately he also we get him
out of the meter burn too agent
yeah it's gonna be a lot of to HR
Cervantes as well you know pretty much
one of his best buddies like to age sex
and things like that right get the burn
it's got two bars available they have a
nice push again you naked enough to be
punished by five a well Yoshi ancient
cells two meters to work with the D
burns one now even if he does lose the
round you would still get another one
for free
Wow both having so much patience right
now not risking anything oh yeah cease
all labors we move off because he didn't
want to have to deal with a possible
shield on the wall he's delaying not
actually teleporting towards him because
the second he teleports heard them
linkers yeah was gonna probably be
looking for on the clock and the to be
is gonna do it range this is Ed send
Chan coming all the way from Singapore
versus link boys
and I'll pcs on we go put that work real
quick we use a lot of bar for that but
that was super good in terms of damage
and positioning right push them up
against the wall it's gonna make this
door right here
oh nice block on the low that time all
but there it is the yer you might be out
late Gor is gonna take down Shan Shan
first round here some new york-style
baby we out here I'll see you he said
your those glasses came off man
yours came off whoo did you know what
don't worry guys that's not the end of
Shin Chan's tale Vicky's run through
loser side oh wow link wars will advance
the winner side yeah so for those of you
for those of you who may not know did
the format the the top eight and in this
Invitational everybody starts and
winners as if it were just an
eight-person bracket so yeah that that
was every match coming up up until you
know we start cycling through the
players people will be going to lose is
we we will be seeing the second chances
from them
so exactly speaking of our contestants
will be having up as Nexus go keys and
also low low that's right yeah